bản chơi thân yêu của tổ quốc, vinh dự được thực hiện nhẹ vụ cách găng như ngày này.
Chúng tôi chào dân nghiêm tự hào, xuống lận, vì được nhân dân cả nước, chào người nghiêm tin,
tự tổ và nghiêm vụ cách chơi, giúp biển.
Chúng tôi, quyết tâm sẽ mại sắc i chi, luôn luôn cải giác sẵn sàng trên đấu,
vấn tay xuống bảo vệ bình yên biển chơi của tổ quốc.
Để đã hội đại biểu tòn quốc của lần thứ 14 của đạo.
Được dễ ra ăn toàn từ đối và thành công tốt đẹp.
Chúng tôi, luôn tí tưởng và ký vọng đại hội lên này sẽ có những chủ chương, quyết sách đúng đáng về như vụ bảo vệ chủ quyền đạo của tổ quốc.
Quang tâm đầu tư hơn nữa để xây dự và phát triển hại quân nhân dân Việt Nam thực sự là lực gượng nong cốt trong bảo vệ chủ quyền biển đạo thí liệu của tổ quốc.
Đứng về đại hội đại biểu tòn quốc lần thứ 14 của đáng.
Quân và dân đã khu trường xa luôn đặt trọn nằm tin và ký vọng và những quyết sách mang tính tổ phát triển lực của đáng.
Sẽ mở ra ký quyền phát triển vượt bật đường đất nước tiến gặng và bên vững đại sống dân dân này khẳng âm nó hành khúc,
với thế của đất nước không nừng được năng cao.
Tung tội cũng ký vọng đại hội lên này sẽ phát huy và năng tầm những quan điểm quyết sách lúc đáng về như vụ bảo vệ chủ quyền biển rời,
biển đạo trong tình hình mới đặc biệt là quân những chi trách quan tâm đầu tư hơn nữa để tiếp tục xây rực đặc cuu trường xa,
trở thành chúng tâm kinh tế văn hóa sau ở trên biển của cả nước.
Bình và dân đặc cuu trường xa xin nữa sẽ luôn nếu cao tình thần cạnh chắc,
sánh sản chiến đấu để bảo vệ bất trắc chúc quan biển đạo thương liền của tổ quốc và thành công của đại hội.